[Musique]
dernier passage en revue des troupes
avant la cérémonie du 14 juillet une
fête nationale dont la célébration et
cette année toute particulière d'abord
par mesure de précaution sanitaire la
cérémonie s'est tenue au jardin de
l'état et avec des troupes militaires
réduite ensuite un hommage est
particulièrement portée aux acteurs
mobilisés pendant la crise du comité 19
comme pour ces pompiers du service
départemental d'incendié et de secours
de la réunion pour l'évacuation des
personnes dont nous avons récupéré ces
personnes chez elles pour les emmener
vers l'hôpital nous avons procédé à la
désinfection
nous avons en plus du convoyage nous
avons quand même accueilli des gens à
l'aéroport pour pouvoir voir s'ils sont
malades ou pas malade donc on était les
seuls à s'organiser pour pour les
accueillir avec avec la rs nous avons
mis une cellule anticipation en place
pour gérer la crise dans la durée
et puis nous avons assuré au quotidien
tout tout notre
le travail avec le maximum de protection
pour éviter que justement le virus ne se
propage plus de 150 militaires des
différents corps de l'armée étaient
rassemblés le peloton de la gendarmerie
de la réunion de la marine et des phases
oeil du personnel civil est également
été présentés comme les associations les
caissiers les forces de l'ordre et de
secours engagées au cours du confinement
un rassemblement patriotique qui fédère
autour des valeurs de la république
c'est un peu faire le lien entre le
passé le présent et le futur
le 14 juillet c'est bien sûr la fête
nationale d'essai avant tout la fête des
valeurs de la république liberté égalité
fraternité ce sont des valeurs que plus
que jamais nous devons porter parce que
les crises frappent notre territoire nos
populations
les populations les plus fragiles et
dans les valeurs de liberté d'égalité de
fraternité
eh bien nous avons résumé tout ce qui
nous pousse à être volontariste pour
servir l'intérêt général doit servir la
population réunionnaise
après les honneurs au drapeau
[Musique]
douze médailles militaires et deux de
l'ordre national du mérite ont été
remises à des militaires engagés
[Musique]